during the 90s and early 2000s it seemed
like Edward Norton was pretty much
everywhere
he took roles in a wide range of classic
movies including Fight Club American
History X Kingdom of Heaven red dragon
and The Illusionist and was beloved by
fans almost as much as he was lauded by
critics in recent years however it feels
like he's almost entirely disappeared
from mainstream Hollywood here's why
leading the trail despite his hasty
retreat from the acting spotlight Norton
has kept himself busy on the production
side of the film industry since 2015
he's been listed as a producer on Lewis
and Clark a long-awaited HBO miniseries
about the two famous explorers who
trekked through the Louisiana Purchase
at the dawn at the 19th century taken a
long time getting it all together but we
finally ready and we're starting to
shoot at this summer
unfortunately filming on Lewis and Clark
shut down after only two months thanks
to an array of further production issues
the series still has no release date
calling the shots in over 20 years in
Hollywood Norton has only directed one
movie keeping the faith a 2000 rom-com
about a Catholic priest and a rabbi
fighting over the woman they both love
Norton has recently returned to the
director's chair however with motherless
Brooklyn a 50s crime drama adapted from
the novel of the same name perhaps
unsurprisingly motherless Brooklyn has
been the subject of some controversy a
fire on location destroyed an apartment
in March 2018 leading to a lawsuit
against Norton's production company for
recklessness carelessness and negligence
the same blaze also claimed the life of
firefighter Michael Davidson whose
family subsequently issued a wrongful
death lawsuit against the company
working behind the scenes one of
Norton's most recent roles came thanks
to Seth Rogen's animated movie sausage
party in which Norton voiced Sammy
beigel jr. in anthropomorphized bagel
who sounds suspiciously like Woody Allen
both the character and his familiar
sounding voice was Norton's idea we all
just you know calm down a notch please
let's try to be I don't know amicable
I'm Sammy bagel jr. I'm happy to meet
all of you
Rogen told deadline he really latched on
to it and was a huge proponent of it and
said from the very beginning that he
wanted to play a bagel that sounded like
Woody Allen Norton was also instrumental
in getting sausage party made in the
first place
encouraging Rogen and his
collaborator Evan Goldberg to stick it
out when the going got tough and
convincing other big stars to voice
characters in the movie including
Kristen Wiig and Salma Hayek a major
bomb Norton's most recent major role
came in 2016 s collateral beauty despite
a stellar cast and some pre-release
Oscar buzz however the movie flopped
hard at the box office earning a measly
31 million dollars in the u.s. largely
because it shared a release date with
rogue one critics panned the movie - and
collateral Beauty ended up failing to
provide the comeback vehicle for Norton
that it's so easily could have been
family focus though he's usually pretty
cagey about publicly discussing his
personal life Norton has opened up to
the independent about his decision to
ease up on acting he cited his personal
and family life as a reason for this
highlighting the need to strike a
balance between acting and what he
called other things that are really
compelling or interesting or challenging
to a different part of your brain or
your personality the conversation soon
turned to Norton's view of the film
industry as a whole he said I just think
that I'm less interested than I used to
be in like exploring genre for the sake
of it he went on to explain that he
prefers to take roles in movies which
are innovative or unique or are helped
by particular filmmakers he respects
such as Spike Lee or Wes Anderson
doesn't quite explain sausage party
though roasting Marvel in 2018 Norton
made a rare televised appearance as a
guest at the Comedy Central Roast of
Bruce Willis naturally Norton made some
harsh jabs toward his moonrise kingdom
co-star but much of Norton's routine
appeared to simply be a setup to attack
Norton's true nemesis Marvel saying I
did a big action movie called The
Incredible Hulk I thought we should try
to make one Marvel movie that was as
good as the worst Chris Nolan movie but
what the hell was I thinking
boy
[Music]